boeing is getting a boardroom shake-up
as it suffers major losses chief
executive dennis Muhlenberg is being
replaced next month following criticism
of his handling of the 737 max
controversy the new aircraft remains
grounded by airlines worldwide following
two crashes within five months industry
regulators need to approve new software
before takeoff clearance is given where
Roslyn Jordan Jordan joins us now live
from Washington DC and the pressure
really has been mounting on Muhlenberg
in the end it wasn't the resignation it
was a firing wasn't it well especially
if you take a look at the press release
which Boeing put out earlier on Monday
it does appear that Dennis Muhlenberg
was fired even though the press really
says and I'm quoting here that Dennis
Muhlenberg has resigned from his
physicians as chief executive officer
and board director effective immediately
the statement goes on to say and again
I'm quoting the Board of Directors
decided a change in leadership was
necessary to restore confidence in the
company moving forward as it works to
repair relationships with regulators
customers and all other stakeholders
that's a pretty damning statement coming
from one of the world's biggest job
multinational corporations one that has
an integral part in many countries
airline traffic and certainly one that
has not just cost the lives of 346
people since October 2018 but also has
cost the company more than eight billion
dollars since these two fatal plane
crashes Rosalyn Muhlenberg might be gone
but what is it going to take to get
boeing back on track and get those 737
max aircraft back in the skies well as
the quota from the board of directors
are indicated first the 737 maxes
software is going to have to pass muster
not just with US airline regulators but
probably with European airline
regulators as well that's a critical
problem the training of pilots on the
737 max is going to have to be of the
quality and again it's going to have to
satisfy regulators in a number of
countries before this plane is allowed
to return to service it's also going to
be a question of getting the confidence
back of major carriers that rely on the
737 for so-called short haul flights
flights between one and five hours or
six hours long that includes the major
US airline companies which had really
built their business model around
putting the 737 max into their fleets
because this plane has been grounded it
really has disrupted their economic
plans and it has affected their ability
to offer more flights to their customers
so the domino effect as it were is
really having a financial impact but it
also is making people very nervous about
whether they should be trusting
themselves and their families to Boeing
products right now Rosslyn Thank You
rosiland Jordan lived--a from Washington
DC